puisque nous allons passer cette soirée
ensemble autant la rendre très agréable
et pour commencer de la musique avec un
concert donné par l'orchestré
philharmonique de berlin sous la
direction d'herbert von karajan alexis
weissenberg va interpréter ce soir le
concerto numéro 2 pour piano en ut
mineur de rachmaninov
puis à partir de 21h10 notez-bien 21h10
georges arnaud et georges ferraro vous
proposeront une grande enquête sur la
sphère moon une enquête ils ont mené aux
quatre coins du monde à bord aux états
unis où vit fastueusement celui que l'on
appelle le révérend moon puis en corée
du sud où est né le monisme en france et
au japon il a essaimé de nouveaux
éléments de réponses arriveront
peut-être à éclaircir cette affaire
23h15 on viens de vous le dire ce sera
l'heure de la toute dernière actualité
présenté et commenté par perdre la rame
la soirée commence place à la musique
avec je vous le rappelle ce concert
donné par l'orchestré philharmonique de
berlin sous la direction d'herbert von
karajan